hey everyone welcome to this interesting
video in javascript
the best way to master a language is by
programming in it
so in this video we bring to you six
simple applications that you can build
using javascript and all of this in 5
hours
if you enjoy watching such tech videos
make sure to subscribe to our channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
so what's in store for you
we'll first create some simple beginner
level projects like the to-do list app
then we'll move on to a quiz app and
then we'll see how to build a calculator
app
then we'll move on to more advanced apps
like the weather app
the tic-tac-toe game and finally we'll
conclude the session by creating a snake
game application
now i'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin
using this javascript css and html combo
mode is called to do application to do
applications kind of general task
manager application where you can attach
add the task delete the task
and uh completed task
very simple and sophisticated
application we will start to start
working with and here we start working
with our first
very simple statement
that this one is called
today so let me go and create a new
folder name called
not here
html and now here
again we would like to start working
with the
html by constructing our css5 will be
well taken care of
so we say
sorry
now inside this
we would like to have some header
portion
okay let me say another type
and insert a step type let's say
id
equal to
this box
after the fetch tool you'll have to use
the textbox
input
text
id equal to
item
and
please hold it equal to give anything i
am saying
title
okay and close this
next we like to use the spam tag
and this is
lc
one click
equal to
now i do not have the function name
called new element but you would like to
create it
okay and
class equal to
given
so after the div tag you would like to
use the uf
url you know that is for unordered list
here i will say
id equal to
list
under this ui tag i'll look for array
and within the satellite you can say
some name
learn
new
is tasks first item
like that i can have some other items
with me
play games
work with the dot like that i can have n
number of tasks which is available to me
okay so here the human tag is getting
that's it
okay
so i do not have a css file with me so i
can just create
css
and this i like to include it in mine
here
link i need to install sheet
href equal to the name called laptop
series
okay so i can have
very simple you can feel for title
nothing is there
add
which must be a
kind of a button for me or whatever it
is
so it is just a span tag for me
on which i will try to click and perform
some action remember this is not my
button
now here once it is ready i would like
to go ahead and talk about my
main thesis which will help me to make
the complete look and feel more better
okay
thank you
so we're going to start working with the
css now
from my css
we want to basically perform
the edit where
close button i want to create it
and i want to create a close button to
hide the current list items in multiple
activities i have it which i want to do
it with my css let's get started with
css now and with my css i would like to
create some basic effects toward my
application
fine so step number one i would like to
say a stick
everything that means for everyone i'm
saying box sizing
border box
basic one
nothing is affected because for common
for all
here i would like to start with my body
now
body
background color
background color i will say light still
blue
i like to have taken
and
background image it's up to me whether i
would like to use it or not
but i can use
height
600 pixels
next background position
that i would like to use center
next is background repeat
because if i do not have any image i
would not be using repeat so
background
size
looks beautiful
well
going ahead we talk about our continuing
partner
okay
so if i just see my previous code which
is there with me that is called
calculator
here in this app.css
i have option called container
so that was my container i just copy
this
and i use it again here
here in container width i would like to
use 50 percent now background color
remain white
align cells
center display block margin
start using
120 pixels
auto and box shadow
border it is not using
padding once again we're not using
box shadow five pixel 10 pixel 20 pixels
perfect
there we go
okay
so this is my simple look now talk about
the ul part now
margin
next order left
sorry
left
six pixels
next list
iphone
style hyphen type
i'm saying none
next party
zero
let's take a look
better
okay
now
so
few things we've used
uh
border left six pixels solid teal
padding now we talk about our ul and
allied part
okay cursor
pointer
next position
related
next paddle
we just would like to use the pixels
like this
background
light
remove that smoke
okay font size
you can select 18 pixels
transition
for
0.2 seconds
for transition
okay and the last option
user icon select
none
perfect
now looks beautiful
you can see now how the effects are
awesome
okay url like that
now
we talk about our positions wise
properties url
array colon
over
okay i say
background color
okay
and after that use your
let's check it
orderlies
background color
again i can use the same
okay
now
after this
we are using this called uli dot checked
i'll be using background
then color
same white
text decoration
line through
which is the checked option
okay
now
after that
check before i also want to use it so we
just say
url
checked
before
you will like check coolant before
content
after that position
absolute
after that water style watercolor sorry
watercolor i'm just using color white
then border style
solid
then bottle width
border
iphone width
bottle hyphen width variance in 0
2 pixels
then top
10 pixels
left
pixels
then transform
rotate 45 degrees
then height
15 pixels
then with
seven pixels
now you see this now
how they look like
the javascript will be applied later on
to make it even more better so we are
just getting it ready for that
okay after that we'll be using for
close and just close using position
absolute
then write
zero
ready
four options we're using it here
okay then afterwards
that's called
talking about color foreign
header will be using background color
tail
then padding
30 pixels
and 30 pixels
color
looking beautiful
well this is your header what we have
written it now
after we will be talking about header
after an input
dot header colon
after
content
colon
and then display
table
after that clear
both
directly input
for input
input i have to make it more better with
margin
then border
then border radius
zero
then width
75 percent
then padding
two pixels
okay then float left
the next option will be font size
i'm using 16 pixels
perfect
nice
so
this is my text box
okay
now we like to talk about buttons
it's time to talk about code button so
we'll be saying dot
at
bt
so
once again the conditions that will be
remain same
we talk about call
paddy
pixels
talk about covet
we say 25
we say background
purple
then we talk about call color
okay and we use float
left
after this fourth left it on for
texturing
center
then font size
[Music]
transition
that's it
change to
so my to-do list css part is over okay
well after this
we're going to talk about our gs file
which is on the most important area of
your code
now here let me close down everything
and start creating another file here on
is called
app.js
the main calculation goes here
so from this point onwards we would like
to start working with a property
whichever we have created here
on the top of that will be start working
here
okay
so
in my css what are the things are
required
that you want to understand okay so we
talk about option called i like well i
stand for what list items
so let's start working with
my list
equal to
document to
get element by id
then
and then
i
press plus
okay later on
document.create
forward slash
span dot class name equal to
close
after that
expand
dot
operation
txt
and then
my node list
i
dot
open chat
so the first function which we had
written it
okay
so there's a name
called node list it's just a typical
logic in fact i would not even say the
function is just a logic which you write
after that
what we need to do now is
we have to start working with our option
called r
close
equal to
yes
and once again
for
zero
price less than
closed captioning
i
dot
on
click
okay close i dot contact
equal to
function
and now here we save our
div equal to
this
dot
style
okay
and now
next thing so this is for when you try
to click on a close button to hide the
current list item
okay so you can say
current
test
okay
now
next what we need to develop the code is
is to basically add a check symbol
okay while clicking on the list item
that means if any item that you
basically click so what should happen
now
so when i so it will get strike saying
that hey this task is over now so you
can save
list
document query selected
here i say check
okay and what should happen now
but before that
i just need to check the condition for
if
e dot target dot tag name this way
give it a target dot
list
dot
toggle
check
okay and here we pass the value called
false
that's it
okay now you have to basically go and
create one of functions for this
so after that i'm going to create a new
function now function
then
input value
equal to
document
dot
get element by id
and after that we're just calculating
this value is saying var
t
equal to
document dot create text node
okay here we pass
input value here and i say align dot
puppet child
of t
like this
and here we say
if
input value
equal to
black nothing is there
then what so in such cases we can say
alert
is basically the validation for me
and let
this
okay this field cannot be empty so this
is the first error procedure showing
that else condition
in else condition it will say document
dot
get element by id
okay which is a type of item
rather than item let's pass list here
and inside this list we'll say
dot append child
and here i will be passing what
i can see
okay
otherwise what will happen we will talk
about this option called talking by id
item
item dot value
equal to
black
okay that's the case now
after that it will start working with
our
span tag now
the span tag will have its own
condition
so first we check about this
and now we talk about how it's fine so
we just say for the span we say
element
document. create element of type
okay so here's what's trending
dot
create element of type 1
expand here
so
after this span we'll be talking about
our next feature now so this
after this is span
will be
yeah so we're now talking about call var
txt
equal to once again
document
dot create text form
we talk about you
so
okay and then
and then last but not least we have to
basically iterate to all
plus
then
close
off type
i
you're passing it dot
on click equal to
function
and here we are saying
div
equal to
the star
parent element
okay and
div
dot
style dot
display
equal to
so
so friends we are almost ready now
because our javascript file is ready
after that we'll be talking about how to
include it in html to take a look well
everybody so we are all set now since we
have our application ready with me js
really sees this will be now in our
index.html file let's just check
how to apply
this gs within my code now so in my
index.html file i'll just go to my at
the bottom of my page
that is called
script
script src
equal to
the
that's it
okay and let's check about my final
outcome
okay so you can see now the crossbar
automatically appeared
okay with my application let me try to
add another one that is called
welcome
so it is automatically getting added
click you can see it is called strike
that means it is done if i try to click
on this it goes off if i click it here
strike click here it's right
add another
it's also working
delete it
click it again it is uncheck or unstrike
form
so guys that's it so we are happy like
finally we have finished one of our very
important projects which is called today
application okay so this time we're
gonna develop another very interesting
example
using this html
javascript and css together and that is
called working with a quiz application
so one of the very very interesting
projects will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all i'm going
to give the name called
html quiz
now i'm going to create a three files
inside this number one i'm going to say
index.html
index.html then i need another file that
is called app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
torches
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first
so we'll go to the html and
see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards dev tag
so within my tab tag
we would like to create
another div tag
okay
so the first top level class
to this particular tip
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so we see
the
class equal to container
now we have got another tab tag inside
this we will set div
id
equal to question hyphen container
question hyphen
container so that is the name or id of
the step
and we say class
equal to hide
now within this step tag
we would like to offer some details
but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tip tag here
and this tab id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes we are just creating
it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this dev tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer few people
like to offer few buttons now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer one
answer one
so that i can have this button class
copy it three more times
and now we can change
the names to
two
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us
dev tag is getting closed here another
tip tag is getting closed here
and now here
before that last step tag is getting
closed we would like to create another
div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's another div tag so under this div
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start hyphen btn
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
btn
space
btm
and we say start here
now just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so
rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next iphone button
next hyphen button
btn and we will give additional property
called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s
capital and
next
two buttons we have created
after this
div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
tab tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span
and here we will say span
id equal to
right hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so
after that the div tag is getting closed
and
that's it
and it last
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this drive tag i would like to close
even before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip tag which is closed
at the end
and here we want to include the script
tag
script
src equal to
script.js
that's it our html page is almost ready
let's review
and uh
yes i can see some standard buttons has
been created
now we would like to look make gives a
better look and feel to this kind of
buttons and
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a route
and with this route some basic settings
we are offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
hue
hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral
value giving a score 200
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen
q
again
hyphen rom
this value we're giving us
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hyphen hue
thus we are making it with the variable
hyphen f1u neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is margin
module will also remain zero
after that display
none
after that not display i would say none
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we are providing width almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contends i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
and this will we would like to use this
var
again this in this world we are using
hyphen hyphen view
and followed by
comma
these things and this is style we
wouldn't we would like to use in my
index.html page so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
refine the styles we always use
link
css so the value is automatically
style.css but we would like to change to
app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better okay so it is only
for the background nothing else it is
impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body dot
correct
body dot correct
we're providing
you
and here you would like to offer
iphone iphone draw
and also sorry not wrong just work
correct
and
we can use
body
dot wrong
body.com
so same thing i'd like to copy
so rather than correct
we're using rock
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
container inside my container i would
like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80
now going forward background color
background color we are offering white
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box shadow we can say 0
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now
we would like to offer the buttons
here in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so
dot
btn
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file
so we have a call button grid
this button grid we would like to start
from here
beating grid beating grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying 2
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then zero
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot btn
followed by the details so
will be using neutral
but
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and
hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
hyphen i want you
followed by
30 percent
okay so these are the values for
border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so
in background color we will just use hsl
rather than this
so hyphen hue
and 50
okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding
just
5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white
for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button hover
dot
ptn dot
or
and for this performer
you want to say border color
this watercolor you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well
so
this is how my
initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use
dot
start
hyphen btn
and also for
dot
next hyphen pt
common look and feel for both
one size
one
dot five
already
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give bold
followed by padding
this padding is be like 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls reset display
flex
followed by justify
contents just justify content services
center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and
last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display
none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start then only the
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is
well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const
and here we will say
start
button
equal to
document dot
get element by id and here it will give
the name called
start
hyphen vtn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like
here
another one
here we change the name
and give the name called
question
container
element container
element
question container element documentation
by id
here we give the name called question
hyphen container
question hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called question element
question
element documented element by id here
will be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers or i can say answer buttons
answer hyphen buttons
answer hyphen
buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shuffle question because
we want every time the questions to be
get shuffled
shuffled questions
current question
index
shuffle quotients and current question
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now once it is done we want to basically
go ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
first question which i would like to
create it here is called question
now here we will say
javascript framework
so which of these
is a
which one of these i would say which one
of these is a
javascript framework
this is my question now
okay so i would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i see text
first will be python
python
okay
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so
i can say true
last i'm keeping its call
false as usual
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create a few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers
so i just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who is the prime minister of india
so we can have two ops answers available
okay
about render mode value is called work
true
second we're going to give the name call
this value is called false
so taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 x 3
i can have many answers
so i'm just making the first is called
six
which is false seconds twelve
like that total we have created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer
one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be nodes called clear
status class
function
player
status
plus
it takes some parameter call element
and here we will say element dot
class list
dot
remove
element dot class list dot remove
and once again i copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
called what
right
and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached
there's only one function attached
that's called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
call
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by using if
correct
then
element
dot
class list dot
add
correct okay
else
use the same option
what will try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use
const
select selected button
selected button equal to e dot
target
number one second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
data set
select button dot data set dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this
set status class function
in the set status class we'll be passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and
correct
is the second parameter
okay now we're using
array
dot from
and here in this editor from we're using
answers
button element
dot
children
okay
followed by
dot
for each here
we're using
this button
as in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called
set status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button
dot
data set dot
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the
main evaluated value called f
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current quotient index
plus 1
then what
then we are saying
next button
dot
class list
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot
class list
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
call if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and document dot
get a limit by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by
dot
inner html equal to
quiz
score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
dot
class classlist
add
height
okay
now
we are using this while option now
answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we will be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is
something which we wanted to start with
okay
well
reset state is already set
now going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
in a text
equal to
question
dot
now followed by questions dot answer
question dot
answers dot
for each and here i would like to use
your passing word
answer as a parameter
now
here we like to create a button called
const
button equal to
document dot
get sorry document dot create element
i'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner
text you to set the value
equal to
answer
dot
text
then
followed by button dot
class list
dot
add here we are
offering
btn
okay now you're saying
if
the condition is
answer dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what then button
dot
dataset
correct
equal to
answer dot
correct
okay
now
the next thing is we are using button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer button element
dot
append child
of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set
next question
here
function
set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state the function we are calling
it
and same
show question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is what the sect
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal to
we have called questions
dot
sort
okay here we say
math dot
random
and
five
we're passing this value
okay
after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are giving 0 right
now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
class list
remove
height
okay
and then
you're calling
set next question which is a function we
are calling it
and initializing our quiz score
with the value called zero
well start game is
ready
next thing which you to start the cover
button
so here we are saying
start button
dot
add event listener
here
in this
on my click event
i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next we'll be calling
next button dot
add event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we are calling current
question index
current question index
plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be
kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so
our javascript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with this
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react
now you can see
it's automatically making the rest of
them as a
red and not giving me the next button
now
the prime minister of india i'm saying
narendra modi
great next and i say
for multiply by 3a12 i say next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask is a flask it says twitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how
dear friends your project is now
completely working
and expected as the way it was designed
for when i
once again restart and you can say start
button now it's giving me four multiply
by three that means it is one second i
have taken
random question so we have decided to
basically develop another very
interesting project in javascript that
is known as called calculator
application
like you have seen earlier some projects
like in tic-tac-toe you talk about snare
game you talk about quiz application
this time we're gonna introduce you
another very interesting project using
this javascript html css
so called calculator application so
let's get started let me try to delete
first those files which we really do not
need it now
uh
we delete those all
yeah now i will be creating a new folder
now and give the name called
calculator app and in this calculator
app once again we need some new files
which is called index
dot
html and we also need one more that is
called
app.css
and another one that is called app.js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html5 where we'll be creating a
template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a god body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator
so that will be my h1 heading after that
we'll start working with the div tag
now within this div
i would have to create lot many classes
i may not have lot many css classes but
we can give some classes here so we can
say class equal to
container
okay
so within this div tag we're going to
create a table now because i want to
organize it
so starting with the table within this
table
tr tag
and within this tr tag i need a td
now in this td i need few things call
call
span
equal to 3
another value and here
i want to offer the textbox
input type equal to
text
okay input text id equal to give the
name new result
that will be the final outcome while
pressing all the different buttons id
equal to result and
class
equal to
screen remember i haven't created those
css classes but but we're giving some
names but later on we can utilize it
while creating the css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now insert this td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here in this input text sorry i would
like to better say button because i'll
be having
buttons
okay
input
button
value
equal to
c
and uh on click
equal to i may not have any function
right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some domain
name here
i'm saying
clear screen
okay so that will be the function we get
called
and after that class
equal to
clear
yeah so this is my button tag
after this our td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another table row
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here
and inside this td i'll be having
another button to be get created
so i'll just say
this is my another button now input
equal to button value equal to
one
on click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call 1
okay and class equal to member
plus equal to
number
and here after that td tag is getting
closed
okay now you have to start another td
tag here
okay like that we have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 on click go to
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what
number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like
now i can see the buttons like in c one
two three but yes i'm gonna create few
more buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here
and create a few more buttons so this is
where the table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this
and paste it again
i have to create
the button
like in 3 4 something like that
so after this 2 we're giving the value
called 3
here
i'll give the value call 3
so val equal to 2
equal to 3 display 3
and then afterwards
just giving the value call
forward slash
and here also we're going to keep the
value call
forward slash
and here class equal to
operator
after that you have to do the value
count four
and then followed by five six seven
so here we give four
four
five
six
after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about call 7
then we have to have eight
okay nine
okay after that we're giving call plus
and display
plus plus equal to operator
operator okay so
here
you can see the table data is getting
closed and here the table is also
getting closed
and after this table row you can start
working with
another table row here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
again
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is valid equal to
dot and here we give the value called
decimal
okay
now display zero
so after giving this dot to basically
take what the value
0 which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called 0
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have another one
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that
we'll be once again
taking this this time rather than giving
this 0
we'll be using this call as a button
and value
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this will not be passing
anything
it like a normal function
and plus equal to
equal
okay
so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we will be using val equal to
multiplication
display
plastic and here we'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table is
getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your dev tag is also getting
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome so we have got
all those
necessary calculator behavior
which
we wanted to
reveal
okay
now our next statement will be once we
are giving this c then we have called
one two three
and then forward slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so
let me check whether we have used six or
not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before
minus
equal to
number
okay so we're almost set now
so we are having this uh
look and feel
in this way giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then plus related behavior so we are all
set now and after that we'll be
basically applying the css as well as
the javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
this outlook is looking properly or not
see what my expectation is after one two
three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next and then
seven eight nine and again forward still
but i can think this is absolutely
unorganized so after this when we say
this forward slash which we have used
after hyphen
okay your td is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start
another tr here
okay
so that i can put them into the another
level now so under this tr i can use
this td now so after this minus
after four five six
minus once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
okay
starting another tier after that we talk
about 789
okay plus
see here talking about 789 plus here the
table is getting close and it is
starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which i
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it later on
okay because you can see eight is
missing right now
so here
seven
we copy this
equal to eight
eight
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized
so the moment i expect my application
so we have a call
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel
so i need to go ahead and use what css
because without css i really can't
utilize this in a proper way so i have
to start working with a css friend now
in css front
how to start first we will go back to my
code and here in my css we'll start
working with
font family but before font fabric i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using called teal
that looks nice
okay so
i will be using this app.css
in my html to see the look how it has
been appeared right now
so in my index.html file
on the top under my head section
link
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css
we want to use
some h1 color tool so here
we would like to use the h1
texture line
center
color
white
margin drop
margin top we'd like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement will be called screen so
we say
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
diagram color gray
and after that border
sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
we're using this
then we talk about cursor
what are the default cursor is
okay then padding
you would like to save 10 pixels
and then
margin
say auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want that's for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me
and rest of the details we'll be showing
you one by one and now we'll be talking
about call input
okay
input
type
equal to button
for input
i say
background color
change to what
right or else i can say
let's smoke
okay and
when the button is active
what i want
let me copy
and put a little button and here i say
active
and this color should be orange red
like this
you can see now how it is basically
looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about color
operators
operator should behave different so i'm
saying dot
operator
in this operator we say background color
background color orange
okay and padding
i want 5 pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using call border
sorry
that bottle
i'm using is called solid
and then black
and
after this width
i'm using 100
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursive
it has to be pointed
okay that's it let's check
perfect so they should turn back to what
to your
orange color
and uh
you can see the moment you take my
cursor on it turns to white
perfect and now those were type number i
also want to change them
so for number
for number i want to say the same option
i want 5 pixels
then i need height
of type 40 pixels
then i say color
it looks i want to say called black
dead border
border we want solid
black into access for it
and cursor
okay that i'm talking about decimal but
decimal i need to have a different
options
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it and i say for
light blue
padding 5 pixels color black border
solid
black two pixels with hundred percent
height forty pixels five cursor
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light blue
now i talk about
clear
okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color
background color is changed to light
salmon
light sediment
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width 100
height 40 pixels
fine
so cursor
pointer
file margin
auto and margin bottom
merging bottoms
let's check
perfect not looks beautiful
okay
now
here
after giving these details we're talking
what called equal part dot equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so we recall
lightly and
after this
since it is equal so we say padding five
pixels is okay color black fine border
fine with hundred percent high 40 pixels
color and cursor pointers just i don't
need to
it's for dot equal and i want
for container
container
in this container width i want 40
percent
red 40 percent background color white
okay
now
here
padding is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all you have orbit
you see
display
block
which we're taking margin
okay in margin
to pixels
auto
okay now align cells
go to
center
okay border radius
border radius let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
box shadow 5 pixels
black
and party
so these are details i have it now okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell
display block border radius padding
and another
adding 15 pixels we have given audi i
don't need to give it again
margin
okay fine
box shadow let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay so this is where exactly my
application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 we're taking background color
let's bring it below
then align itself
display block
okay margin
okay
and border radius
and uh
fine i think we're all good now
so
that's it so we'll try and implement the
javascript part well every now so our
css file is ready our html is ready it's
time to just uh
go ahead and talk about my
final portion that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just say function
display
function display which takes val as in
parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result
okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay here's the function
after that we have another functions
available here called function solve
here in the solve
we just use the value called let x equal
to
document dot get element by id
result
okay
dot
value sorry
value
okay and say connect
y
equal to
perform the calculations for the using
one function called
libra
and type
access in parameter
now the next statement will be again
document.
get it involved
result
dot
value equal to
y
okay
now
later on
i'll try to use another function here
function
clear
screen
and here we say
here we say
result
dot
value
equal to
like that
so clear screen
solve
and
display three functions are associated
with me and these three functions
are the part of this javascript file
which i'll be calling it
at the end before
the water tag get closed so here
script
equal to
that's it
okay let's try to execute now
here
two you can see the values
i will say plus
six
equal to eight absolutely see let's
clear the screen
six
divided by
two
equal to three awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is the css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in of this template
beautification and here last video for
gs which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay
hello everyone and welcome to the
another very exciting project for our
development in javascript that is known
as call weather pro it is in the
continuation to the series of the
previous project what we have developed
in javascript and this is once again a
very competitive project i'm gonna
present you
which is called weather pro where i
would like to offer you the real-time
weather application
into your browser taken from the
real-time weather applications
okay so let's get started with the new
development of our application which is
called a weatherproof
now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more kind of static in nature where like
you talk about snake game you talk about
tick tock toe or other type of games
like an online quiz where the data was
very much static in nature but we were
presenting the data in the form of more
dynamic in nature this time
this project we are presenting you on
contacting with a real-time weather
application where i'll be making a one
rest api call or else you can say
asynchronous call and since javascript
is working as a what a pure asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the javascript can communicate with your
backend
load the data and represent the records
in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this
vs code editor only just to
develop our code and once again
for developing our presentation part
will be using html for
forwarding part we'll be using css and
to make some dynamic update we'll be
using javascript now here i'm going to
create a new file name called index
dot html
apparently i just want one more that is
called app.css
and another file we need it and
that is called
your js file so you're saying
app
dot gs5
so total number of three files are
available to us so i'll start working
with an html now and here
we'll start
with this
html templates
now here first of all i would like to
load my css file which i do not have
right now but certainly i can use it
okay so i can just say link
area equal to
stylesheet
and href
equal to
app dot
css
well that is my css location
now i just want to create
some
this link area i would better use inside
my head tag that with a more
convenient place
now in my body
i want to have some of the div tags and
there i can decide where the weather to
be displayed so i can just start with my
div tag now
with my div tag i say
class equal to
i can just create a class which later on
i can offer
a different size of or different type of
style so we can say container
so we're saying dip class equal to
container now within a div tag we like
to use another dev tag which is a nested
one
so this step will have another class
called
class equal to
app hyphen
title
i have hyphen title
in the same dave tag we can use
this a typical paragraph tag
and here we say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag
we want to have a text box because i
would expect a client to enter the
detail on which city or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
some properties like id
equal to
search
second type
equal to
text
next placeholder
equal to
enter
the city
next
autocomplete i'm saying autocomplete
off
the reason because i do not want the
previous value user can see in this case
we can say autocomplete
off i do not want any auto complete in
this
okay
now
here it is getting close now
after that we also want the locations
for that i may use some of the png files
and all but right now
i just want to display the details
of the user
like which city he belongs to and
accordingly i can display the records
right in your application
so for that i really need
some of the div tags once again or i can
display
the details
of this particular city so i'm just
having this only text box let me go and
go back and check
how it looks
so i have a call into the city so here
i'll be picking up the city and
somewhere down the line i have to
display
the record
so after this div
we can also have some of the locations
to be displayed
so
we can just use the notifications
and
also the location where you want the
details to be displayed
okay so we can use div plus
class equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so div class equal to temperature
hyphen value
inside this i'll be using paragraph tag
and here in my paragraph i'll say iphone
and
this degree centigrade or whatever you
want to display it here
and we'll use
a spandex within this and show
in degree centigrade
that's it and if you want to define the
temperature description
after this dev tag we can use another
day of tag
and inside my tip tag
i can define the temperature description
okay so we can sit here
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
and within this i'll be using what
a paragraph tag
here i'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which i want let me check
okay so it's here right now
so now let me try to collect the value
from the client and perform some
javascript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the css features
inside my code now now few things i
would like to say is i have basically
downloaded some fonts which i would like
to use it in my application and i also
have some of the icons which i would
like to use
during my application presentation so
there are some png files are there which
i have downloaded from the internet just
to bring more beautiful experience
towards my application development
well there's another background image
which is called bg.jpg which i would
like to
make it as a background of my
existing application so i'll start with
my css
and see how this css can really bring
some new features to my code
well
first thing i need to have a call font
face so to make this font face we are
using this statement name call here at
the rate
font face
and
i like to use font family
font family i'm using
mod select
okay
it is already there with me monster it
and the url
what is looking forward for so we are
saying src
url
and i'm saying under the
font
so we have a file called tdf
okay that is called
bolt.ttf that is the file which is there
with me
next thing
so
for every
location i want to use
the font family font hyphen
family i want to use same
monster
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
i need url
and in this url we can say
bg.jpg
in my background
next thing is background color
that i needed steel blue
then i need height
i'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
this i needed is center
next is your background repeat
i say no repeat
next is your background size
this i'm saying cover
this is my body part okay let's check
okay
looks awesome now you see this now this
is how
my weather is looking like it you can
see like the background looks awesome
now now next thing we required a
container
so we are saying
dot
container
container we say width
with 50
next background color
we're just using white
next we needed it is your align itself
that will be
center
display
will be block
margin
so in margin we can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius using 10 pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box should be giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my container so
index.html file we have a call container
now
okay looks awesome now
so this is where exactly the details
will be
okay
now
after this css
container we have used
we can talk about called title
you can say
hyphen
title
inside this we will say width
will be 100
then height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
then we need display
display we need flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying center
next we need justify content
that will be the justify content which
is center
then flex direction
would be column
so this option we are using for our tool
name called what
app hyphen
title
okay so here in my index.html file we
have a called div class equal to what
our python title
equal to weather info let's check
okay
so
this is another
we have used that is called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph
so here
this app title
tab title space p
but it should be the class so we are
saying dot
and there also we have to use what
dot because both have to be the class
type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference i forgot to add
dot and now you can see it looks better
comparatively
paragraph
so once again in my paragraph i will be
having texture line
center
padding
i want 15 pixels
then i need margin
margin would be 0
and
auto
followed by font size
font size
this i'm saying is called 1.2
yeah
this position
then color
we are giving
hash
value call 333
okay
now here
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well
going forward for the search
because if you remember
we have an index.html file we have a
call id code to what
search so here in my
app.css i have to use hash
search
okay so this search conditions i want to
use it
now inside my search i need few things
one is called display
i need block
after that i need margin left
auto
margin right
contour
width
i'm looking forward for 5 pixels
height
that i'm looking forward for 20 pixels
then
border radius
i'm looking for four five pixels
then outline
that's called none
when we say border
okay
in this border what we can say three
pixels
space
solid okay and once again
see
that's what
let's check
so this is actually the text box
so once again search your views display
block
margin
left auto margin right auto width 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing i said
padding should be 5 pixels
width
should be 40 percent that's why it is
smaller but it will be
let's check
yeah let's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready
i'll be having some of the details for
the notifications also
so what i need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
now in notifications i would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving white
and after that we using display
and we're saying
none
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by
its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all we
are saying color
color is basically red
okay else if you want to give maroon
it will the model
and
after this
the next property we are taking is
called font size
one size we're taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is zero
after that texture line
center
adding 10 pixels
0.
so this is for notification p and then
the weather container
okay in my weather container i will say
width
hundred percent
sorry
yeah with hundred percent height
height we're giving 260 pixels
or if to you 250 pixels if you want
background color
this background color we are giving is
called once again white
and followed by margin top
20 pixels
pixels this is for weather
container now for the weather icon
weather iphone
icon i am saying width
is
and height
128 pixels
just to give in a better look
now the next thing we are using dot
weather
icon icon
space img
here we can display
none
and
sorry display node none is another block
display block and margin
giving 0
space auto
therefore
i can and location icon if i want to
give then
location
iphone icon
this location icon i can save with same
width height
so
width i'm giving is 100
then
height i'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option called
padding
then take pixels
so it's for location icon
now
followed by location icon we are also
giving call location icon img
okay dot
location hyphen
icon space
img
here we're giving the value called
display block
display block width
we're giving is called 32 pixels
then we're looking forward for margin
margin would be 10 pixels
and
auto
then cursor
so cursor will be pointed for sure
and then we required padding
padding looking forward for 5 pixels
followed by border
water we are looking forward for steel
glue
steel blue
solid
and 2 pixels
then border radius
border
radius
we're looking forward for 10 pixels
and followed by your color
steel blue
so these are the look and feel we have
to basically offer it for my
current application which i yet to
discuss in my
next development
then i'll be having some small small
properties here
okay
and those properties are nothing but to
give you the details of
like
temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen
value okay this temperature hyphen value
we can give it
is 100
and height
we're giving this call 60 pixels
okay this is for temperature value let
me copy this again
and
i'm giving this temperature value space
paragraph
here i'm going to give padding
margin
then color
which color you're looking forward for
so we can just say dark grey
okay for any color which you're looking
forward for it's up to you now but if
you want you can change the color answer
to another one we're giving this call
hash
okay two five one
okay that is the more perfect color for
this development now font size
4 em
then followed by texture line
and once again center
so this is for
temperature value b
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value p
then you can use a temperature value
span
here
dot
temperature value span
space
spam
and here
we go the additional dot
now whether this is pan
say color
once again save
and font size
this is for
span
and in the same temperature description
paragraph you can use it
dot
temperature iphone description
description space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
then margin
followed by color
same color the one which we have used
earlier
after this color just set texture line
center font size
1.2 am
this is for temperature description
okay
glass which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now dot
space 3
here we can say
margin
then padding
then color
same color i would like to use
after this color texture line
and font size
and copy
text align center and here will be given
0.8
okay and last which is really left with
called tip
in that
relative
hair position
i'll be using
absolute
top
from top
i'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
i'm using
120 pixels
that's it
okay so all set
so you can see now
here we have to basically offer the
details how my pictures will be taken
attack so this is what my css now will
be applying some of the css into my
applying the css into my html to see how
it really looks like
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
okay so we have seen some of the css
classes we have introduced
in my html
we have used this uh
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used tip classical temperature
value okay if you just check carefully
we have used this temperature and there
we have used temperature hyphen
value
but before that we would like to use
some other properties too
okay after this autocomplete equal to
off we want to use
uh another div class
okay before my previous date tag is
closed here so here
after this we would like to use another
div tag
div
here
in my tip
i'll say
class
equal to
location hyphen icon
location hyphen
icon
okay and here i'll be using img
src
equal to what under
icons i'm using the file name called
location
dot png
and alt equal to we leave it as it is a
blank
okay now here the div tag is getting
closed
okay
now there's another dev tag is getting
closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another div class for
notification here dev
class equal to notification
dev class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another tip for the weather
condition
another div tag and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
whether hyphen what
a condition
or i can say whether iphone container
whichever so i can say
whether hyper container
under this
weather container i like to use
another tip
for weather icon
tip for
class equal to weather hyphen icon
weather hyphen icon
and within this
i want to use another img
src equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot png
okay div tag is getting closed
so after this dip tag is closed i'm
gonna use
um temperature value
so the temperature value is anyways used
here if you see
raising call temperature value after the
first f tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used after that the paragraph tag
and the temperature hyphen description b
after the p that the div tag is getting
close
okay and after this we are using div
class equal to location
so we want to use
div
class equal to
location
and within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
[Music]
with this
hyphen after this paragraph exists close
this tip tag this tip tag
and another tip tag three div tags are
closed
that's it and at the last
before my body tag is closed
i would like to use
script
src equal to
app
dot
js
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now
so
this i
want to be display only when i don't
find the weather and the location
anymore so broken field is absolutely
good and now i'll start working on my
javascript front
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our javascript code
so in this javascript code first of all
i need few things
first thing what i need is call
individual elements or individual
properties of my application i need cost
icon element
i can element equal to
document dot
query selector
and i'll be using the name
call
dot
weather hyphen
icon
okay
now
copy this
now we will call icon element we can say
location icon
call
location
icon
here we are saying
dot location
icon
now
next
i need it is called temp element
here using
the property call dot
temperature hyphen
value
space
p
next we are looking forward for
desc element which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyphen
description hyphen
temperature has been description space
what
then location element
okay we need location element and we use
dot location
space b
next we need notification element
notification element and here we're
going to give the call modification
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements
next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this statement is all about
selecting the arguments the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying var
input
equal to
document
dot get element by id you'll be given
the name called
search which is the name or id of my
text box let
city equal to
blank
next we're gonna keep score let
latitude
equal to zero point zero we are
initializing this value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input fields
next we want to apply the elements here
we are saying input
the variable dot
add event listener
the variable what we're talking about
which even list will be talking about
key up
okay
up and what even you want to apply so we
are saying
function
with a parameter name called what
event
and now we would like to attach the
logic now
we send if what is the condition
event
dot
key code
equal to
okay
then that means number 13 is basically
the enter
see the key code means for 13 13
represent the enter keyword so even dot
key code equal to what 13 so here
say event
dot prevail
default why we're using this because i
do not want my page to be get refreshed
just to avoid this we're using this and
after that we are saying city
equal to
input dot
value
now
you'll be using this another function
because i do not have function created
otherwise i have to call the function
name called get search weather and be
passing this as a parameter so we're
going to get
search
whether i do not have this function i
yet to create this
and pass it here as a what
city
and we say
console.log
city whatever we are basically printing
it
okay
so that is the first thing
later on we need to get the data so to
get the data we are just using this
variable name called const
whether
equal to
const whether equal to
curly braces
after that we are saying weather dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want i'm saying unit
of type what celsius
i want in a celsius put it in a double
quotes
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in kelvin i'm saying
cost kelvin
equal to the value of the kelvin is
about 273
and after that
con c ultimately what we need is
we need to interact with our backend api
from where i will
get or receive the updated weather
applications
okay
now
to get this i'll be using one very
popular api here that is known as call
openweathermap.org
this is a very very popular app
which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear
so here what you can do this
open method map.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular
unique
api key
since
as a visitor you really can't get it
unless you register yourself so i have
my api key with me so i'll go here
it'll ask me for the registration
so
i already signed up so if you're not you
need to sign it there's an api key for
me which i need to copy
and this api key i'll be using it in my
project
so i just use this property called const
key equal to
to paste my key here
okay
after this paste in the key but make
sure that you rather using my key you
use your key otherwise this application
sometimes won't work
so i'm basically trying to use this tool
name called geolocation
i'm saying if
geolocation
okay in
navigator navigator is you know there's
a
browser object model element
so here we're using
navigator
okay
navigator dot
geo location
dot
get current position
in which i'll be passing the first
parameter name convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case
if any error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
i'm using this statement name call
notification
element
you see this notification element dot
style
dot
notification remain dot
get elements by class name
but i don't need this rather i will use
what the style
dot display equal to
block
then i will be using the same
notification element dot
inner html
equal to
you're gonna use a paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
so you have to enable the current
location of yours
okay that's where exactly
so after that we have to basically set
what the user position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location we'll be just using another
function here
function
set
position
it will i'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position dot
chords chords for coordinate star
latitude
like that
longitude
equal to
what position dot
dot
longitude
after this we'll be using this function
called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon seen i'll
be having it defined below but as of now
we are just saying
get weather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this function name called
what
set
position
in which will be passing all the values
okay at the same time
i will be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
i would like to use location
icon the one which you defined on the
top part
add event listener which even listener
i'm saying
one click
second
function which take
even doesn't parameter
and inside this i'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey
just
and
we say get weather
okay once again you'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same i just copy
this
and paste it here okay everyone so we
have written till here when i try to run
my browser
so i should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined
but obvious because this message what
we're writing it here is called show
error
okay this as a function as a parameter
it is not defined let me define this
function called show error so we are
saying
function
show error which take
error as in sorry just take
error is in parameter
now in this we are using
notification
dot
style
dot display equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element
dot
inner html
equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
error
dot
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and
now see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if i say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment i click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because i told you
this get weather function i need to
develop so i get to develop this
function called get weather but before
that i'm using another function called
function
get search weather
get
search weather in which i'll be passing
what
city name
now
what exactly my api will be in case if i
want to make a call i will be using let
api equal to
now the url will be what
http
colon double forward slash api dot
open
weather map dot
org now open weather map dot org
slash
data
slash two point
sorry two point 2.5 that is a version
slash
weather
okay question mark
i have to take the city dynamically so
i'm saying weather
question mark q
equal to
here
we're using what city
and
we're using ampersand
app id
equal to the one app id we have used it
already
okay what is that
that key
so that is the key
which we have already written so that
app id we are passing it right over here
okay q equal to ct and have id equal to
this
now after that to make the restful api
call i'll be using one independent or
by default api which is available to us
that is one is called what
fetch
okay so if you just check this fetch it
is basically a take requestion form
and give you the what a promise response
so return type will be the promise type
in this fetch i'll be passing what
the api
and will be using dot
then that means if the request
is successful we are saying function
function
response
then function as a parameter response we
are saying let
data equal to
response dot i'm expecting the response
of type of what json
using json now and return what
data
so it will be returning data back to me
now if it is successful then what then
i'm saying dot then once again it is
chaining
again
function
data is in parameter now in this case
we'll be getting lot of things
i'm saying
whether
okay dot
temperature it's a predefined dot
value
equal to i'm using what
math
dot
floor inside this we are passing what
data dot
main
dot temp it is a predefined property we
are receiving it now
hyphen
kelvin whatever the kelvin value is
basically we're taking score 273 on the
top
minus
kelvin
followed by
another property what
weather dot
description
equal to we're using
data dot
weather
zeroth position because it contains lot
of data but i will be taking what
description out of that
then
weather dot
icon id
whether dot icon id equal to
data
dot
weather
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather dot
city
okay equal to
data dot
name
after this
weather dot country
dot
equal to
data dot
sys dot
so these are the properties i have it
right now with me
okay and once i received all the
property i'll be using dot
then
i'll be using one function
and i will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but i'm gonna say
there's a one function name called
display
weather
this function i had to write
but this function just putting it here
okay
now this is closed
after that
since i need to get a weather from the
api provider
so i have to also pass what the latitude
and longitude which i'm receiving it
from the client because
here i just want to have two things
the properties as well as whether both
and both i'll be using it one by one
okay so here
we have kept this get search weather and
now i'll be calling one more function
after this logic and i'm giving the name
call function
get weather
okay it takes two parameter one is
called what latitude
and thing is called
longitude so we have two things called
latitude and longitude
and here i'm using this property called
what let
api
equal to
once again
if you remember uh
i have used this statement i'll just
copy the same
and
pass it here
but challenge would be this time
i will not be passing city name because
the two options are available either you
type the city name or else you click on
the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this feather question mark
here i will not be using q i'm using
what
led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using
and
hello in
equal to
we're using longitude
okay and app id equal to what key so
this is the variable which we have it
now
okay
similar thing which we have used it on
the top
okay called fetch api
so i just copy this same fetch api again
because i really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code when we
know it very well it can be similarly
done i just copy and
paste it here
so the same fetch api
dot then response data equal to
response.json return data then
whether the temperature method flow says
country.display weather so we have used
the same thing here and after that we
have to use the last function here that
is called display weather
display
weather
and here in my display weather i can use
what
icon element dot
inner html equal to
i'll be using
img
src
equal to
icons
slash
dollar
and we'll be passing what together
okay dot
icon id
png
okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot png and after that
it is closing that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
so rather than closing this i'll be
closing that and
this i'll be closing it here
now
we'll be using top element
sorry temp element
temple event
dot
inner html equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
weather dot
temperature
dot
value
okay
and
after this value we can just use
this asterisk sign
the one which i told you
okay and use
spam
ok next we are using call talk element
so we have
sorry dsc limit
we have got dec element dot
inner html equal to
weather dot
description
and last but not least location
element dot
inner html
equal to
what
i'll be using once again this
and here
weather dot
city
comma
dollar
weather dot
that's it
these two properties we have to use it
and we're all done
let's check with my code
if i get any error
now
allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds globe undefined that's
perfectly fine intercity
you can see awesome beautifully it is
showing you the conditions it's saying
smoke 28 degree centigrade and now let
me put another city here i'm gonna say
called pulley
awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and
let's see one more
i would say
awesome and now we are planning to
develop one very special game for you
in javascript and now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known for tic tac
tic tac toe is
favorite game we have already played a
lot in our childhood days and still my
favorite game so i have decided to
basically offer you this tic-tac-toe
game
developed in
javascript html css which can create
something really very great effects for
the end users so let's go and start
developing our next game that's called
tic tac toe
so in this tech tactile i will start
working with creating a folder called
tic tac and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called index
dot html
now here onwards the same thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but so we're going to create some div
tag now
so in this div tag
i'll be creating some of the tags
in which the css class will be applied
so we just gonna create a classes
uh for i'm gonna just use those classes
but we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create those so we are saying
div
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
div tag inside this i'll keep
my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tim here we
say
h1
and inside this h1 we give the message
called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic tac token
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for layer one
or else i can say player 1 and inside
this let's do the name called
player
label is closed
and
after this label will start working with
our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to player1
next we want id
equal to
player one
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're gonna close this this is
my first text box
and
same thing i would like to create for my
another one
so the first div type we have used let
me go and create another tip tag
in this div tag i'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after this div
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
dev tag is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now
so here we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show
some containers where the details will
be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check that
is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name in the name after the stick tag
tool
so
yeah
so here the details we have taken input
applicable text and input applicable
text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div and inside this div
i says i haven't created any css classes
so those we can use it later on but
let's have
this div
and inside this div i would like to use
a motif type
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so
in this div we can just give the value
called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value
we are passing it
div data id equal to 0 the div tag is
getting closed
fine so
that's how we want it now
so here
the first div tag is closed like that we
can create another data id so 0 1 2
total number of three we want to create
it so i want to create 0 1 2 3 4 5 like
this
so the way we have created here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
id equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
two
three four
five so zero one two three four five
total number of five we have created
one more i would like to create it now
here for six
there will be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
and
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
board or button that you can basically
offer it a little later on
but here
we can use one more tip
and here we say do
dip classical relative
and within this div tag i can use
any image tag if i want
so i just leave it as it is
and after this
i can create one more div tag
and insert this another tip
okay
and
under this i'm going to create
a button
okay and in this button
we'll be having some value
okay we can secure the value name called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
span
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so
here is just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there's no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me more better look when your
application will start but most
importantly i need to start working with
the javascript part where the logic will
get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included the javascript with
my code
so here
i can see here
script tag
script
equal to
now the file i haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style sheet answer so
i just say
link real quick start sheet
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our consideration now
we'll be creating this css as well as
the javascript to make this example
complete
well we are ready with our html but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js
and inside this we will start writing
the logic with our main application okay
now the first thing is how we're going
to start now
yeah
so first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but i can give the name called
app
which i'm gonna create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i am saying let
gameboard
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that and one more
for making it nine
[Music]
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay
now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create let
turn
this new variable
equal to
zero
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player it's turn
like which player turns it to b so just
it is trying to mention it i'm saying
let
winner equal to
false
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
player how are you going to create a
player we say const
player equal to
what we're going to pass
name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
name that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
and inside this
input field
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id
here
we're going to take
the class name of this particular
text field so we are saying input
icon
field
okay
dot
oops
okay now after this we have to say cost
add layers
once again
dot
get element by id let me just give the
new call player form
okay next we are saying
add
layer
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
and here we say
sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener
which even i want to say
click
ok that is the first event second
reset board
reset
board
that we are basically passing that
okay
now
this is the initial case which we have
it
now beyond that i will add
this is the place what we have added and
write nut slides to add the players so
this is how we have initialized after
that let's
add
players
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add
players
okay it will take
event as a parameter
and say event
prevent
prevent default this present default
will try to prevent
the default
you know behavior which is submitting to
we get avoided and now here we say if
this
dot
player
one so we just define the property call
layer one
if this dot player 1 dot what
value
okay
is
blank
okay or
this dot
play two
sorry
this dot
player two
now i just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i am saying alert
you
must
enter
name
for
each the user has to add the values and
after that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this inside
this by saying cost
layer
form
container
again
const play from controller container
equal to
document dot
query selector
document query selector here we will
just pass
the value
call
enter iphone
players
okay now we say cost
board main equal to
document
dot once again
query selector
dot
class list
dot class list dot
add here we're giving the name forward
height container
all right
add
and after that you just say board mail
board main
dot class list
dot remove
height
hyphen
okay so we've basically taken that
and after this what i will do i'll just
say player
x
dot
name
equal to
this dot
player 1
dot
value
okay this is for player x copy this
player y
two
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which
we've implemented
well so
add player function is added right now
and uh after this add player we have to
basically call one more that is called
which returns the current player so i'm
saying return
current player
and here what i will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
test variable
okay percentile
2 we're just adding it with this
okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you
okay or else
so we're adding like the current player
who says the current tail right now
well
after this adding the return current
player we're gonna add another function
that is known as call rate of the
current player return current player is
having this value and after that we need
to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized
once again if the browser is getting
resized automatically the square size of
your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we're gonna save this option
equal window
dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here
and the second parameter what we are
parsing is called on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is a function name for me
the one which we are passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal to
document
dot query selector all
in this we are passing
board
underscore
cell
okay and then we're using another option
called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set width
or
after that we are saying all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
cell
[Music]
and after that we are using cell
dot
style dot
height
equal to now he'll be using this
backtick and use this
dollar sign
and say
cell
height
and that tool in a pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's right over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
build port
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document dot
once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value called
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also
okay so for those functions i can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add
sell click listener
but i do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
your own
okay so we will just leave those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt
to make move so
here we're trying to say
sell
click
event
for
player 2
attempt
to
make
move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function
and give the name of the function
to make move now
function
make
let's go back and try to check another
condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
power sent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what
event dot
current target
sorry
dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values
after that we use another variable
called let
cell 2
add
token
now here we are typing document
dot
query selector
and here
you know using backtick i'm using this
value called
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay
so this value we are taking it like that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell
to add token dot
inner html
extrometry mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token dot inner html
equal to blank
then what next
so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay so
in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current set dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell
is
already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to active
consuming cell to add token
okay dot
text content
equal
to current player
okay and we say
game mode
the one which you have created pass in
this game mode
this value call current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
send
to add token dot
text content equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for
is winner to check whether the user is
winner or not so we are saying
is
winner
okay and
after that we are saying
turn
plus plus
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being
and we'll call this little later on so
leave it as a full time name
okay so your function is now ready so
the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not okay so we are saying
function
check
if
i we're just taking the function
whether it is game is tie or not so here
we say
if
the condition is turned
greater than seven
alert
okay well after that we are saying
winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we will check
const
winning sequences
and here
sorry
here
we are having this array and having the
different conditions associated we say 0
2 probability we are checking it
and then i just copy it
well missing 0 1 2 and here is saying
5.
six
seven
eight
and zero three six again
zero
three
six
and once again one four seven
four
seven
and next we have a call two five eight
eight
then we are checking the value zero for
it
eight
and one more last option we will put is
called two four six
six so these conditions we are adding it
now
after this array we can say
varying sequences start
for each
and give the name call winning compose
winning
combos
and inside this varying compost we are
giving let
cell 1 equal to
varying combos position 0
then
that copy
and paste three times
cell two
cell three
and here we get the value called what
one
is two
three values we're giving it and after
that
we are checking the condition
let's say
if
and here the conditions we are checking
what exactly that will be for the game
board we are saying
game board
set
one
current player
sorry current player
ampersand time percent
come down
game board
sell to
i just want to copy the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
cell 3
after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
by cutting this condition called
consense
const
sense
and then equal to
document dot
get element by or sorry document
selector
queryselector
all
and here let's select the position dot
board
underscore
cell
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside is what we are passing we are
saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
pressing if
cell id
now we're talking about call cell id
triple equal
to cell 1
or
select
cell 2
or
salary equal to
cell 3
okay and in that case we can use
cell dot
class list
dot
add
and get the name board
just give the class name
winner
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
current layer equal to
document.getelementbyid
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current player or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
layer we can use
the current player text
the new variable we are creating it
currently text document dot rather than
saying get it event by id
we can say
query selector
and in this query selector you'll be
given the value
by saying dot board
player
hyphen term
the value which you are giving it here
and that
query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it in a
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just checked
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
currentplayer whatever the value we are
using current text
dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you see
congratulations
along with
this dollar sign
and here we pass
and here the tip tag is getting closed
like
this okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it
and after that
we give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to true
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written
we'll be talking about a little later on
and just say return true again
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition a filler
if
winner
or we can say
check
if time
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board
header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us and here they
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case you have to say let
current player text
equal to
document
dot
query selector in this you will be
getting the details like dot
or
and here we gonna give the name called
player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put it in capital letter
here
x
then we will say
current player
dot
inner html equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backticks because i want
to go multilines that's the benefit of
this backtick and here we say in our
inner html span
class
equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
style
close this and here we want to use
the statement
now this
value
we want to write it with name attribute
so it is getting closed and here we are
saying dollar
with this player
x
dot
name
and then close the
span tag
and we say
you are
up
like this
and after that
we say dev
class
equal to
we're just going to create a class which
later on we can apply the css style on
the top of that u hyphen r
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div tag
so dip tag is closed
that's it and now after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current layer
text
dot
inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we gonna write the span
class equal to here we say name
hyphen hyphen same option we're gonna
use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
this thing rather than copying it again
and again
i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to
name hyphen iphone style player rather
than saying x you can use file
you are up you are
winner
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we need to do
create another function called reset
port
function
reset board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using the game board
and the same game board what we have
used it earlier
i'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember
that was the game board for me so i'll
be using the same keyboard we copy this
yeah
with the same condition
okay game we go to this
after that line we will say let
cell to add token
send to add token equal to
document
dot query selector all
here
in this i'll be using another class
called
letter
now
cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square
and within this square we would like to
use square
dot
text content
equal to
black
after that
square
dot
parent element dot
class list
dot
remove
and here we would like to say board
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these changes classes were just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to 0 because we are resetting it n
winner equal to
false
after that when is equal to false we
just define another variable called
define it current player text
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all
so here
we're gonna use the name called board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
currently text dot
inner html equal to
once again we have to use the condition
for
up
and winner point so let me try to copy
this
inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
sales equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's check
the condition board
board
sell
and here once again we say sell stock
for each
dot
and here this is cell
add
event listener
which event i want to listen
click
and the second parameter will be handler
ones called
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell
click listener
now here we say
let
all
cells
equal to
document dot
query selector all
let's
pass board
cell
and now we say
all sets
dot
for each
cell
and here we say send dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here most of
our javascript code is written now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create
our html file now sorry the css
so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i am going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.css in either folder like in static
folder but i have just kept it outside
now from this point onwards i would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called body
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay uh
but i don't think so it's really needed
it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background color
because it's by default going to be
white only and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position
i just say like center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
they're using cover
okay so it resize the background image
to cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes so first select
div
dot relative
inside this data alternative is first
say call position
position we are saying absolute
next is top
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right is saying 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height
dot
container or sorry hide hyphen
container here in hide hyphen container
we will display
display
colon
none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside this header we will say color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next
margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family i am selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that's called dot
enter
hyphen
players
now in inter hyphen players are the same
color
will once again
we can use another layer but we can just
use white or any color you want
or you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we're giving it's called zero
auto width
we're looking forward for eighty percent
next texture line
center
position
relative
now
next we're going forward for input field
in this input field we just say border
border two pixels
solid
and black
next
outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
four pixels eight pixels now margin
we are saying zero
zero ten pixels
okay and finally
for pixels
after this margin we say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
focus
now here
border
two pixel
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want your submit button to be so
i'm saying
dot
submit hyphen btn
border
two pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
18 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 pixels
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take
white only
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate
with your submit button active and
submit button focus so we are saying dot
submit hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outline
outline
[Music]
next border
we're talking about two pixels
solid
and the color
red
okay
so that's the one
and after that we like to use over dot
submit hyphen button
colon
over
what you want
change the background color
to what white
you can use white smoke
well
here we like to use
a
dot
board
here we like to use player
hyphen
so these are the classes we were using
in our javascript we remember
and here we say color
we're using once again
white or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
texture line
center margin
10 pixels
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style
and here we are saying color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about a
next important called border container
called board container dot
board container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay
next margin
we are taking is zero
and
auto
after that font size
font size we are taking 0
next border
bottle we are taking 2
pixels then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
you remember this worksheet is one of
the very very seasons three popular
property here we're defining three
pixels
three pixels
zero pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about call black
okay
so my
border color will be shading color will
be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining 100
okay divided by three
this calculation after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
center border
we are taking
2 pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
this formula can use permanent
permanent marker
okay
now
next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board symbol
board
cell iphone
winner
i would say rather
now
spelling wrong this has to be d
yeah
winner
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
next transform
translate y
to minus 50
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay
now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're giving
winner
the dot
dot
winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container
what are the values we want to use it
that's you want to basically do it so
for this winner container what i would
rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
texture line
center
margin
20 pixels
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset heading we will set
display now
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah
now we could talk about replay button
dot
replay hyphen
vta
and here width
we make it
to
25 percent
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on outline
i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this letter spacing would be again
zero
after that
text transform
this text track form value we're talking
about call
uppercase
next font size
font size we are taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay now in a similar line we can also
have
call dot
replay iphone btn
colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
then color
we are making is called white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
so we'll be using this
dot
okay
so this congratulations
class will be using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r
dot
winner
in this winner we'll be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking little pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two pixels
and then zero
okay
that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
hyphen
btn this i'm saying with 50
so this is what my css file is all set
i know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch so we have this index.html file
with us and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known as call
this
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this
using this external api so here where we
have a call css with us
before that
we want
link
so within this link we want our
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent
plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know
where exactly it is using
okay if i just copy and paste it
so i just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com
slash oh spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url
from where i can take this kind of font
so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it
so here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the
final outcome of my code
which is
index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class r attached so i need to
attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes so that at
least i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a part tip h1
class equal to header
tic tac toe then we have a call tim we
have a call
body
uh
under this we have a call another dev
tag so
just imagine how many type of classes
are available one we have called tip
class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a
called one more div tag so like that
multiple css files are there where we
have to apply the new css class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added
all those type of css classes which we
had that is called enter player
player form player container label
placeholder
and player container
and if you see all different type of
classes we have attached this to
okay because
here only my css class will get applied
and the javascript will apply those kind
of dynamic css based on certain
conditions so these css classes are
already there added inside your html
page
our app css is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like it
awesome so it looks like pretty nice tic
tac toe is a game it is expecting and it
says start game it says you must enter a
name for each field validation is
working
let me try to
add two names and says start game
awesome so now you can see it is saying
a you are up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the tic tac toe
game is used so it is a classical
example of css javascript and html
together
so this time we're going to talk about
our next very interesting feature that
is known as called dealing with another
example that is called snake game so
staying keep is one of the very very
powerful example which i'm gonna share
with you which will help you to
understand like how
we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project
okay that is something which is a snake
game let's see how the snake game is
important and how we're going to deal
with this
these are our previous examples which we
have seen which i will call a project
which we have created that is called
quiz application and now we're going to
start working with our new project
now here first of all i'm going to
create a new folder
that is called snake
again
and inside this is a game we need some
new
folders
first folder i'm going to create it
inside this that is called
images and
within this snake games i'm going to
create few new files that is called
index
dot html
and here
i'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot
js
at the same time i'll be having some of
the css files if i need so i can say
app dot
css so total number of three files i
have it now let me close down all the
files whichever i have opened it earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach
this is a snake game for us from where
we need to start
and we have index.html file and here i
will i think you will create
our basic html syntax
and uh here i would like to include
our script
tag script
src equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing our next
implementation of snaking
now inside my body tag
i would like to have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on i'll be taking the
input from the client so we are saying
input
type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give id
equal to
gamespeed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value
and
min equal to
1 that is the minimum value
and max equal to 9 that is the maximum
and minimum value we can offer beyond
that i won't allow the users to go
and step
that means the increment value that is
one
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button
and
value
equal to
start
and then id equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after that
i can give some
bricks
so two bricks we're giving it and start
working with the div diagonal
and in this div tag i'll be using the
canvas
it is a html5 feature
we use canvas
and i just give id equal to
game
area
there is a canvas
and
after this canvas
we will
that tip tag is closed here after the
div tag i can use another tip type
div
here i can say
class equal to
i may not have any class written but i
can say
class equal to related so later on if i
want to apply any css style
i can certainly apply
and after that i can offer the images
okay so i may not have any images right
now so i just leave this image playing
right now
okay and this is script src i'll load it
only
before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on a bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so i can see
values
now it will go maximum nine that is how
we have given and minimum is one
start is the button which is not doing
anything but later on we can allow some
logic inside this
now we have to start working with our
main javascript tag
this is my amp.js and here onwards we
will use
some of the properties okay which i want
to initialize it so using r
game
start
equal to none
initialized
second game speed
equal to
next game area
null
game area context
area
width
equal to
zero that is in integer value
game area height
game area
equal to zero again
then solve it
solve it equal to zero
play score
equal to zero again
next snake
equal to null
next snake food
next sneak direction
equal to
null
snake speed
or else i can say speed size
speed size
equal to
zero
next we have our timer
so these number of properties
we've initialized
okay
now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here in initialized
we would like to use some of the
properties
first we are saying
game start
equal to
document dot
get element by id
here i can give the value called
game start
let me put it in double quotes
again
start
now game speed now these are all
basically the values are there game
start game speed
these all values we have to take it
okay so we will be seeing these values
one by one so let me set another one
that is for game speed
game speed equal to again
document dot
get element by id now we are passing
the game speed
[Music]
game speed
now
here once again i will take another
point game area
i say game
game area
here you have to give the value called
okay so these values we have taken
now we will be talking about cool game
media context
gaming context equal to
game area
dot
get context
okay
and in this game context we'll be using
what type of context using 2d
okay because i want to have
the kind of 2d so
this is how the kind of environment we
want to set
next we talk about game area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
game area height
equal to 600
now solve it
we're initializing with 20
next game area dot width
okay so game area
dot
width equal to
game area width
and then we define game area dot height
dot
equal to
game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this
okay
now after that we have to start writing
the logic
here i'm saying game start
game start
dot now we have to line
uh which event you would like to take so
i will say on click
on
click
so when i basically click
what should happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here i'm
saying this dot
this dot disabled
equal to
true
so i'm going to disable these values
and after that we want to call
another function inside this
but which function let's do that so here
we are saying function
start game
start
okay
and
here in start game
we want to define the initial score see
the initial score for the player will be
certainly zero so we say
player
score
equal to zero
after that
direction in which direction you want
the snake to move so we are saying snake
direction equal to
right
in the right direction
then speed size
the value also the variable which you
define so speed size equal to because
it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it certainly will be string type
so we have to use car sent
so we're using this option called power
sent and here we're using
game speed
dot
[Music]
value okay so we are using this value
gain speed dot value now here we would
like to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay
what if condition
uh
see this function we are writing called
start game
because there are certain things which
you need to
make it
so like that we have to define it so
function initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
on click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started
start game and now we'll be writing the
logic for this so here we are saying if
we're saying speed size
missing if
speed size greater than
in case if it is
the values hard-coded it
then we would like to write a logic here
and what this logic would be it says if
it is greater than nine we say speed
size
equal to nine
we basically initialize to what nine
here we say lsf
speed size
is
zero
we say speed size
sorry
speed size
equal to one
that means if it is less than zero i'll
be making it minimum to one if it is
greater than nine i'll be making it to
nine maximum
and that's it
okay
so after this else if condition
is getting closed we are seeing speed
size equal to
one
so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards by saying x
position
zero
and
then the y
and here the y value will be what
celebrate that means how far it can go
so it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call cell width
which we have given here
after that what we have to do is
we have to define our own function
called
clear interval
and this clear interval perform any
logic whichever i would like to make it
okay so here after that snake.push value
has been given
here i will be creating one more
function here that is known as call
create food okay so here we are saying
create
food
so create food will be the function for
me now you might be thinking where this
function is but this function will be
declared soon within your application
but here first we are saying the
function called clear interval
clear interval
with the timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that
this clearing treble will be saying
timer equal to
set interval
with this we are saying create game area
create
now
here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement
so
here we are giving this call create food
is a function we are calling after that
we are calling this clear interval
clinton will be just like in a typical
function which is there after that we
are using this option called create game
area
so
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you
how you can call this function create
food and how to create it first well so
we are talking about a functionality
called create game interval so this
create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the saying set
interval
this function is noted there so we have
to basically go back and create this
function within my application
fine so
what we will do is just particular one
we will try to comment it for a time
being
okay so here we have a call what create
interval
in this create interval will be
passing any parameters which we are
passionate about as a timer here and
here we are calling this call create
food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
in this function create food let's go
and write a logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food we say snake food
disney port equal to
and here in our curly braces we use two
direction x and y
we say in x we say
math
dot
around and inside this we say
math
dot
random
after this math.random function we have
to just take this calculation
and check the another parameter called
game area with
game
area width
minus
cell width the one which you are passing
it and here after that we'll be
performing the calculation by saying
solve it
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similarly we would like to use for my y
coordinate also
now
math dot round round dot number gave
area
game area height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
solve minus
let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay
so that's where exactly it's got closed
now here
our applications is now ready by calling
the function called create4
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so you're saying
function create game area
create
game
area there's another function for me
after this create game area there will
be another function i'm gonna create it
that is called control
function
control
okay after that we'll write one more
function called function
right score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call right score
there's another function which is going
to write it down here that is called
function
right score is done now we say create
square
create
this is another function
and finally we'll have a call change
direction
function
change
direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it
here in our system
well
we know very well that we have taken
this call create food grade food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
great game area we are defining two
location var
x direction and y direction so we say
snake
x
equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we are saying dot x
for the x direction
we are saying var
snake
y
equal to
snake
position we are taking once again zero
and
dot okay so two directions we have taken
x direction and y direction
now here we are starting
gain
area context dot
fill style at the united variable it is
a property
fill style equal to which color you want
to fill this up
so i'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this game
area context again
dot fill react
fill react
now keep the position values i'm saying
0 comma 0 comma
game area
game area width
comma
game area height
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stock style let me take this game area
context again
dot
stock style
stroke style
equal to now we give the another color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same gave me the context dot stroke
react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
comma
game area width
game
area
height
so we are passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic of the directions
now see the when you talk about snake
game it move left right and center
up and down so now in this case we have
to increment the situations accordingly
so we say if
the snake direction
if the snake direction
go to
right
then we say snake
x
plus plus
now
else elsif
elsa
same
let's copy this
snake
direction left
then what should happen
here we say
snake
x
minus minus
okay so we're taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're taking about left right we
set down
in this case this is snake
y
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
let me say
snake y
minus minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this else if condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that we say
if
snake x
f snakes x
minus 1
or
snake x
double equal to
game
area
width which we have taken
divided by
cell weight
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus one
okay so we're giving this call minus one
or
snake y
stack y equal to
gain area height
to save it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah we will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created some time back and inside this
control
it will take some parameters so what
those parameters we can pass and we can
say
snake
x
comma
snape y
third parameter will be snake
so this could be my another function
okay
so here
we are passing the conditions just like
that
okay now here
this is
available to use a parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for right
score
which is so far the function is only
created not
described more so we're writing the
right score score will be written here
and here we are saying clear interval
because the timer will be stopped
okay i'm using game start
dot
disabled
equal to
false
and after that
return
that's it
so this is the logic for we have written
to this particular example
now we can use
another if more conditions here just to
check the behavior of my code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
well here we have finished this
game start dot disabled equal to false
and we returned
now
going forward after this return
we would like to have another condition
for the snake x so we say if
snake x
if a snake x double equal to
snake food
dot x
okay let's make four cortex
ampersand
snake
y
double equal to
snake
food dot
y
then in this case i will say
var new head
bar
new head sorry
var
new head equal to here
x
colon
snake x
y
colon snake
snake x and y colon
snake
y
these options we are taking it
now after that we are using this option
called player score
plus
equal to
speed size
and then we are
calling create food method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this as condition
we are saying var
new head
equal to
snake
dot pop
okay and we are saying new head
dot x
equal to snake x
and new head
dot y equal to
snake
y
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
dot unshift
and shift
snake dot and shift and here we are
passing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for loop by saying
for
var equal to
r i
i equal to 0
then i
is less than snake dot
length
and
snake dot length
and once i
plus plus
okay later on we just use the option
called
create
square
and in discrete square we are passing
snake
snake position
i
dot
x
comma
same
snake
dot y
that's it
so it's getting closed here and after
that we are calling the same option
with this snake food let me copy this
again
and here rather than
using this we can say snake food dot x
and snake foot dot y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now let me start working
with your control
control needs to take three parameters
x y and the array so we are passing this
option called
control and in this control we are
taking x comma y
comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
var
i equal to zero
i is less than
array total
length
and i
plus plus
and after that we'll be using this
option called if condition and here we
say
array
i
which value we are passing dot x
double equal to
x
ampersand time percent here we say array
with a position called i
and in this we are saying dot y
and this position we are checking for
the y condition
for the y condition so it returns what
true
written
through
the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return were
false
now that's it now we are talking about
this option name called right score
this right score we have to use the game
area context
game
area context dot
font
equal to here we'll be passing this
situation we using 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
sends
iphone
service
after that we're using a media context
again let me copy this
take it again call game area context dot
fill style equal to here i'll be using
the another color now
so we say hash
okay
now after that we are saying once again
the game area context dot
fill
text
here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say
plus
player score whatever it is
with game area width
game area width
slash
minus
and then
again
game area with
slash two so this is where exactly the
right score where the data will be
actually written
okay next we'll be having this option
called create square and this great
square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about call x
second is taking y
and now here we're using this game area
context
same
dot
fill style
equal to let me give the color
after this we're using call same gary
and text
game area text dot
fill react
here we are saying x
multiplied by
cell width comma y
multiply by
sell with
comma
sell with comma
circuit
this is what
my great square is now we are left with
only one option that is known for change
direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters
now here we are passing this option
called workkeys
equal to e
dot
and
later on we want to say if
is
equal to
okay
am percent ampersand
snake direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake direction
equal to
down so we are changing the directions
here
okay now let me try to copy this
and here we use elsif
[Music]
four times
okay
so here we talk this
30 40 and here we say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 27
39 38 27
and here we say up
let's change to what
left
down
right
here we say
up
left
three options we have changed and last
but not least here
i will just use
window dot
on key down
equal to
change directions
and
window
dot
on load
okay equal to
initialize that's how exactly we want to
use now and this function what we have
defined in initialize
okay
so in this initialize
we are having this game start dot on
clicking and all so you have a call
start game now this start game will be
calling it here
okay so in start
we were called snake we have called
snake.push
and after that we are calling
this function called what
create food
clear interval and here we say
timer equal to
here set clear interval and here
change
game area
slash
speed
size
let's say you want to use it
okay everyone so our code is almost
ready so we have this complete
javascript code ready with me
now it's time to basically use within my
html
just to check how it may behave
so in my html page
i have written this
normal speed
number
game speed value
button start we will call game start
after that we have a call canvas where
we written id equal to call game area
dev classic to relative
and
that's it and here we have a call script
sr is equal to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if i try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay
i really do not see any changes in my
code
okay
despite i'm having this because the css
content is actually missing
okay because then only my code really
look
better
because if there is no css
it won't really make
good towards my application
okay and i also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
a little later on let me go back and try
to bring css into this picture now so
first of all
have this
index.html file with me
and here i want to use css so inside my
head tag
we want to use
link
real
equal to
style sheet
okay hr
equal to
app
dot
css
okay
now
here
in my css we want to offer certain
details
what those details i want to start
working with i will start with my body
part
body
so we want to offer
the font family
so
font family maybe a little bit later on
i can use it first i want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
auto
later text
align
center
next font size
font size 150 pixels
also 150 percent
and here we want to say background
background image
since i do not have any image so i will
just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise have to say url
and insert this url
it gives some values but i leave it as a
blank because i do not have any image
i will say background color
in this background color i can just use
white
after that height
i can just say 800 pixels
after that
background position
background position i want to use center
then background repeat
background repeat i want no repeat
then background size
okay let's see if there's an effect in
my
okay i see it's now
in the middle
better
now
inputs canvas we have to basically take
that
here we just talk about call input
okay in this input i say font size
font size may be optional i can
make it
but let me just say font size 100
percent
then text align
center
then padding
i want to say 5 pixels
and
7 pixels
okay looks better now
well here after that i can use canvas
in this canvas
i want to see the background color
i just say right
after that border radius
border release i can say 20 pixels
then
shadow if i want to use it
so i just say box shadow
box shadow i can say 3 pixels
5 pixels
and six pixels
and the color is
black
let's check
awesome
so i can see
here the
logic is there so shadow you can easily
see how it has been using
and
that's it and this div
i can say
div
dot
relative
position
absolute
top
here i'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly
i program now when i say start
okay so there may be some error here
then they cannot set a property of call
on click
null
so this
we can just check this into this
gamestop.onclick
let's check
anyways
we just tried to fix that issue in a
while
but anyways we have our created css and
now going forward we'll be implementing
rest of the logic within my code okay
everyone so we have changed some names
here because there was some value was
mismatched so we have basically changed
those values
with your properties and now when i try
to relaunch my application
by
this index.html file
so now in my index.html file when i try
to add
so
it's just as usual same let me say start
and here you can see game start when i
go up you see like it's starting right
now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play it earlier
okay but you can just change the
direction go up and you can see the
score 10 is being placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value call
what zero
by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
right so like that you can see and
automatically this will be positioned
this is what's called food that is how
we have used in my example called app.js
you can see we're using this example
name called food
create food so in create food of the
specific interval time this would be
automatically created and the snake will
eat and increase the size of the code
okay that's it and now the css has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first game which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example
and with that we've come to the end of
this video
i hope you had fun building these
applications
if you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comments section below
thank you for watching keep learning and
stay tuned for more from cynthia
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here